martin biron michel david stéphanie
grammond bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir la
crise du logement on va en parler il ya
l'aspect joutes politiques
puis elle était quand même assez corsé
depuis hier et ce matin je veux entendre
ce matin d'abord monsieur legault qui a
pas digéré risque vu dans les journaux
etc entendu à la télévision prises yeux
mon école je ne dirais pas le moule mais
de voir certains articles aujourd'hui
qui laisse entendre que je parlais de 5
600 $ pour une famille c'est qualifiable
qualifiable ceux qui ont écrit ça parce
qu'ils savent très bien
ils savent très bien que c'est parce que
j'ai dit je parlais les étudiants moi je
suis fier de dire que je viens de la
cave très moyenne je m'assure de rester
proche du peuple
ma mère est encore à sainte anne de
bellevue j'ai encore des amis qui sont
dans la classe très moyenne et j'accepte
tous ces commentaires bon je vous
donnais la parole mais je vous fait
écouter quelque chose d'autre
une heure après période de questions ça
s'est pas apaisée
premier nice est déconnecté mais ça a
l'air d'être encore une fois la faute
des autres
ma question c'est est-ce il
reconnaissait oui ou non une crise du
logement
le nom d'une occupation des loyers à
trois champs mais plus là c'est un des
plus beaux
je ne comprends pas pourquoi ce premier
ministre ne veut pas reconnaître qu'il
ya une crise du logement
mon gouvernement augmenter les montants
à l'aide sociale de façon historique
on a mis 600 millions dans accès logis
sont en train de réparer des godes
monsieur couillard parce qu'il y avait
dix qui créerait quinze mille logements
abordables
puis vint la députée de vaudreuil jeudi
il n'a pas construit sur présidence
c'est nécessaire d'en faire plus on va
en faire plus on va être champions
pourrait des familles bon parlons
d'abord de la l'interprétation et du de
la colère de monsieur legault martin et
ensuite on parler de la crise du
logement mais qu'est ce que peut faire
monsieur l'économiste d'ing nous dira
peut-être pas grand chose mais je vais
avoir votre avis mais d'abord mais cela
vous été choqué martin ce matin ouais il
était fâché parce que dans le fond de
voir qu'il parte ou que le qualifier de
déconnecter du terrain c'est quand même
son identité politique c'est quand même
sa marque de commerce
il savait qu'ils seraient
et qui serait prise à partie le faisait
longtemps que les partis d'opposition
veut pas eu une telle opportunité de
pouvoir attaquer monsieur legault sur
son propre terrain alors monsieur
legault devait brouiller les cartes
c'est ce que fait il ya semer le doute
ah c'est bien possible que monsieur
legault ne savait pas le prix d'un loyer
médian lavado faire longtemps que louis
un logement il peut pas tout savoir et
je pense pas que ça c'était dans ses
cartons proche mais avec ce qu'ils nous
ont dit c'est aussi possible qu'il
parlait des étudiants écouter ces faits
il n'a pas d'ennemi depuis plus de vingt
ans alors ils iront le bénéfice du doute
ce soir
oui parce que madame massés dans son
préambule on va écouter plutôt parler
des étudiants alors lui a dit moi dans
ma tête je parlais de la part d'un
étudiant dans un appartement collectif
qui peut être de 5,6 en avant michel
david
d'abord sur la réaction monsieur legault
ce matin qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé
ben j'ai bien vu comme tout le monde que
monsieur legault et a pas de bonne
humeur
évidemment pendant des années il a
accusé effet les brouillards d'être
déconnecté alors ça fait renvoyer la
balle comme ça ça lui a pas plu et je
peux le comprendre parce que c'est
embarrassant mais
je pas dans la tête de monsieur legault
l'âge alors est ce que vraiment il
pensait aux étudiants en disant ça comme
martin le dis je suis pas certain que
même sans la référence aux étudiants il
y aurait eu la bonne réponse mais
monsieur legault là c'est un homme
politique d'expérience il connaît les
médias ils devraient savoir que la clip
qu'on va retenir la il faut qui m'a tout
ce qui est important dans et à l'appel
dû commencer sa phrase en dix ans pour
des étudiants
ça peut coûter 5 ou 600 $ parce que de
la façon dont il l'a donc c'est la
formule et les deux interprétations se
valent ouais c'est fanny c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être un peu ambigu on peut
pas être le goût puis déterminer qu
est-ce qui est qu'est ce qu'ils
pensaient vraiment mais ça reste que ça
fou peut-être me collait à la peau comme
philippe briand va à l'époque où il
s'était retrouvé à dire qu'une famille
de quatre
on pouvait faire l'épicerie d'avec 75
dollars et ça avait un peu frappé
l'imaginaire parce qu'évidemment c'est
vraiment beaucoup d'argent donc est-ce
que ce que monsieur legault va voir
réussir à convaincre tout le monde qu'il
n'y avait en fait que c'était pour un
étudiant qui est en colocation avec
plusieurs autres personnes
mais sinon c'est vrai que ces deux
d'ignorer même si ça fait longtemps que
même après louer un logement c'est dur
d'ignorer que ça coûte beaucoup plus
cher qu'elle soit parce que c'est
vraiment un problème majeur est depuis
plusieurs jours on a fait des articles
dans les journaux et pour montrer que 1
900 dollars on peut avoir un taudis avec
des coquerelles avec est de la
moisissure donc cesser de notoriété
publique là qu'il ya un enjeu majeur de
ce côté bon alors c'est mon lot de
questions retour de table martin sur
l'acceptation qui est une crise du
logement
je le go et prude have pas à coller ce
mot là or stéphane il le dit la presse
le devoir
ici on a fait aussi deux
breux reportage sur le fait qu' il ya
déjà égorgé par la part de leur budget
qui met un logement pourquoi pourquoi ne
pas reconnaître ce moule à ce que c'est
dangereux pourquoi est ce que monsieur
legault a dit c'est qu'il pense que ce
qui se passe actuellement est due à la
pandémie
c'est sûr que puis je fais un petit
croche je reviens un peu sur le
politique c'est le dossier de québec
solidaire et québec solidaire le même
c'est sa clientèle
c'est sur son territoire est clairement
québec solidaire a gagné la semaine
politique
monsieur legault est forcé de faire un
effort parce que le tout le monde
réalise qu'il ya un problème de logement
puis c'est pas juste à montréal il ya
aussi de madeleine ses héros le % le
taux d'inoccupation alors il ya des
crises un peu partout est ce que
monsieur legault à 10 et je veux pas
intervenir auprès des propriétaires je
veux pas forcé de faire bouger le marché
je suis prêt à donner de l'aide directe
aux familles qui en ont besoin pour
boucler leur budget qu'est ce que ça
veut dire si c'est pas très clair parce
que de toute façon y'a verrier dans les
cartons de la cat sur ceux sur cet enjeu
ni même dans les cartons des libéraux
qui ont un point de presse diffusé ce
matin
oui même élu monsieur l'économie se
disait si tenté qu'il y avait une
intention d'agir à court terme
c'est pas évident parce que il y aurait
fallu qu'on encourage les entrepreneurs
à créer des édifices à logements ce
qu'on ne fait plus on fait des condos
ont fait des maisons on ne fait plus de
ces grands grande bâtisse où il ya 15 20
30 50 cents logements à loyer à michel
david
même si je voulais agir à ce que d'après
vous il ya un espace pour agir d'abord
monsieur legault a démontré kicanas sa
peau bien aussi
et tout ça a commencé quand sa mine et
c'est vrai aussi de tout gouvernement ça
a commencé cette histoire là quand la
ministre responsable de l'habitation la
madame la forêt a donné une entrevue à
la presse
ou d'avoir à nier qu'il y avait une
crise et d'autre part de toute évidence
à comprenait pas les tenants et
aboutissants la de la dynamique du
logement et monsieur leubou dans ses
explications hier à l'assemblée
nationale
disons que ça sans éducation et a
passablement simplicité à écouter le
québec s'enrichit on rattrape les autres
provinces bas c'est normal que le prix
des loyers suivre sans penser que
l'accroissement de la richesse et plaide
pour répartir équitablement
alors à partir du moment où il comprend
mal de problèmes il est clair que la
solution est pas évidente à ses yeux
elle n'est pas d'ailleurs au mieux non
plus le j'écoutais comme vous
l'économiste un taux qui nous expliquer
quel point le problème est compliqué oui
même eminem
même si on bat ceux des logements combat
tout seul ça va sortir de terre dans x
années la police les gens qui ont un
problème c'est 1er juillet ça règles
strictement rien n'arrête
est-ce qu'il faut geler les loyers comme
en ontario monsieur me loge je pense au
nom de l'économiste nous expliquer les
effets pervers que ça pouvait avoir
mais j'en crise et de groupies l'appeler
autrement mais il ya un problème puis il
faut qu'il irait au quai ses fans et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez comment
comment agir doit de réagir
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment on est dans
une situation extrêmement tendue
imaginé il ya même pas encore cette
année une amélioration était beaucoup
plus faible en cause de la pandémie donc
ça c'est des gens qui arrivent et qui
généralement s'en vont à logements alors
imaginez si on avait eu ce flot des
migrants plus jeune est ce que ça allait
donner
donc oui où il faut il faut il faut
trouver une solution mais ya pas de
solution facile mais je pense que le
problème vient du fait aussi que depuis
des années il ya une réglementation sur
les loyers qui fait qu' on invente ici
pas et que aussi on rénove pas donc on
se retrouve avec des appartements qui
sont dans un état lamentable
mais les propriétaires est ce qu'on peut
les blâmer si l'on sait si c'est très
difficile pour eux de récupérer l'argent
qu'ils investissent il n'y a pas de
logique financière
enfin alors peut-être que la solution se
trouve aussi de ce côté-là le dire
d'accord un donnons un peu de lest 1
permettant aux propriétaires de
d'investir davantage et donnera la
chance de faire un plus de rénovation
qui est à augmenter le prix des loyers
pour deux façons d - le démesuré mais
tout de même
mais contrôles ont aussi d'avoir
davantage les augmentations parce qu'en
ce moment ils demandent le loyer ne peut
pas augmenter plus que d'un certain
montant de l'an dernier dans le grand
dans le grand montréal l'augmentation
moyenne c'était 4,2 pour cent c'est déjà
un record depuis 17 ans mais pour les
lots les loyers qui étaient les
logements étaient inoccupés donc
l'augmentation était de 30 pour cent
soixante que quand le logement est vide
mais le propriétaire surprend c'est sa
surface mais même s'il n'a pas le droit
le nord
ils devraient c'est pour ça que des gens
qui disent on devrait créer un registre
et tous les loyers mais mon entreprise
on serait en mesure de limiter cette
augmentation la important quand le cas
par 100 voix contre une
mais ça ça fait est ce que c'est la
bonne solution à voir mais je pense
qu'il faut rétablir un équilibre parce
que si personne n'a intérêt à bâtir de
logement ou à les rénover mais le
problème restait entier est il de dire
oui c'est vrai que pour déjà ça peut
être un drame de reconnaître cela
peut-être les solutions sont pas
évidentes mais de reconnaître que ça
peut être extrêmement du chef mais c'est
de taper dessus que le marché suppose et
s'auto régule pas parce que les gens
manquent de logements là même si
l'augmentation a pas de bon sens il ya
des gens qui font du programme je
l'apprends pareil
et à partir de ce moment là bas il est
clair qu'il y en a qui en trouveront pas
voilà hockey vaccination un petit mot au
tour de table as-tu monsieur dubé
comme on le dit avec sébastien beauvais
en début d'émission a choisi une autre
métaphore lesélus ciel qui se dégage de
soleil qui arrive martin on va revoir le
calendrier appel à tous 14 mais là on
ira jusqu'au les 18 24 ans alors qu'à
chaque deux jours ça va s'enchaîner ça
va plus vite que prévu ouais bah c'est
sale elle a la mauvaise humeur de
monsieur legault est inversement
proportionnelle à la bonne humeur
le ministre de la santé était vraiment
bien content d'annoncer était à 14 mai
les 18 25 ans 24 à 20 il en a un ça va
vite ça veut dire que ça va bien
probablement que tout le monde va voir
ça dont nous peut-être même avant sa
première dose en fait tous ceux qui
veulent être vaccinés ont probablement
leur première dose avant le 24 juin
alors c'est un succès jusqu'à d'un bon
michel david
oui bah écoutez il ya un vent
d'optimisme qui souffle sur le
gouvernement on l'avait vue mardi et moi
j'avais jamais vu monsieur legault l'
aussie aussie aussie optimiste ce niveau
il ya deux semaines
il y avait le moral d'un talon vous êtes
peut-être au milieu de l'été avait
peut-être un début d'embellie là
monsieur dubé nous dit aujourd'hui on
est en train de gagner la guerre
alors ça ça va très bien aux yeux du
gouvernement et sa voix objectivement
bien la vaccination roule à un train
qu'on avait pu imaginer
encore une fois quand on se compare à
l'ontario c'est vraiment pas le paradis
mais enfin ça va très bien et l'objectif
du 24 juin va très probablement être
dépassé alors malgré ses malheurs dans
un autre dossier
monsieur legault a de quoi se réjouir et
nous tous ça roule bien
ce souci l'horlogerie de la vaccination
à bien régler pour l'instant où il puise
son nom il faut le dire pour le répéter
le québec est en avance et la famille
lavalas favorise qui est le cas vacciner
le plus derrière la saskatchewan donc
c'est un c'est un beau fait d'armes a
souligné maintenant moi ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est qu'on arrive dans une
tranche d'âge dans d'étranges l'enjeu
vraiment ce seront des travailleurs qui
vont devoir être vaccinés alors ça va
être bien que les employant maintenant
pour la roue des gens on voyait des
liens îliens regroupement grandes
entreprises qui vont faire la
vaccination c'est tant mieux il ya des
d'autres entreprises comme un e-mail qui
donne des bonis 50 dollars si vous
faites vacciner 25 40 premières doses
25-25 la deuxième il ya toutes sortes de
stratégies la carotte ou le bâton est ce
que des employeurs aussi qui vont
décider des deux des plus restrictifs
ainsi on se fait pas vacciner
donc moi je pense que là ça va être au
aux employant 9,1 leurs phares et
y'avait gabriel nanou vous voilez ya
quelques temps qu'il disait on pourrait
avoir un congé payé comme pour les
élections on est constamment au lieu
d'aller là parce que franchement il ya
quand même plus de deux possibilités
d'aller se faire vacciner que d'aller
voter avec une journée précise dans
l'année mais tout de même je pense qu'il
y aurait il
regnauld pour les employant d'être
flexible époux d'être conciliant de ce
côté là bon ben on se quitte sur une
note positive
bravo merci pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit